what is austrian economics in this
beautiful whirlwind picture that you
painted okay austrian economics grew out
of the new out of the
rebellion against the classical school
so you had three intellects who mainly
led the growth of the neoclassical
school back in the 1870s was william
jevens from england uh menger who's from
austria and volras from france and
volras tried to work out a set of
equations to describe a multi-con a
multi-uh product economy where there's
numerous producers and numerous
consumers everybody's both a producer
and a consumer and you try to work out a
vector of prices that will give you
equilibrium in all markets
instantaneously and that's his
equilibrium orientation jevons is also
one about equilibrium but he worked more
at the aggregate level so there's a
supply curve in a demand curve and
that's what gave marshall ultimately
codified
menger was pretty much saying that well
yes there might be an equilibrium but
you're going to get disturbed from it
all the time you'll be above or below
the equilibrium and what came out of the
austrian school was an acceptance of
that sort of vision that the market
should reach equilibrium but then say
well you'll get disturbed away from the
equilibrium and it's that's what gives
you the vitality of capitalism because
an entrepreneur will see an arbitrage
advantage and try to close that gap and
that will give you innovation over time
and schumpeter went beyond that and saw
the role of money and said that
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is somebody
with a great idea and no money
yeah okay so to become a capitalist
you've got to get money and therefore
you've got to approach the finance
sector to get the money and the finance
sector creates money and also creates a
debt for the entrepreneur
and so you get this financial
engine turning up as well
and you will get movements away from
equilibrium out of that you won't
necessarily head back towards the
equilibrium so schumpeter has a rich
vision of capitalism in which money
plays an essential role
in which you will
be disturbed from equilibrium all the
time
and that is really i think a much closer
vision of actual capitalism than
anything by
even even the the industry-leading
austrians
you know hayek uh et cetera et cetera
they they and certainly ron barto i find
totally like reading a cardboard cut out
version of uh of the wealth of the
wealth of nations it's uh i find his
worth trivial um
but sean peter was rich but with the
same foundations as the austrians but
because he talked about the importance
of money that took him away from the
austrian vision which is very much based
on a hard money idea of capitalism
sean peter said you needed the capacity
of the financial sector to create money
to empower entrepreneurs
and that's a very important vision so
sean peter's argument is the deviation
from equilibrium that's where all the
fun happens that's how the magic happens
that's the magic of capitalism and like
the austrians because they focus on the
deviation from equilibrium are better
than their classicals but they still
have this belief in the you know you'll
reach equilibrium ultimately or you'll
head back towards it uh whereas they
don't they don't have an explanation of
capitalism that gives you cycles apart
from having the wrong rate of interest
okay so there's no role for an
accumulation of debt over time so what
champion gave us was
a vision of the
creativity of capitalism being driven by
entrepreneurs who are funded by money
creation by the finance sector
and that's
fundamentally the world in which we live
you